[Applauso]
quando ero piccola coloravo sempre le
panciotte delle lettere in modo tale che
le parole potessero sentirsi più piene
compatte forti sicure è un po' l'emblema
della mia vita e ora vi spiego perché io
mi chiamo Angelica nicorica e ho 20 anni
ancora per le prossime 12 ore e questa
sono io quando ne avevo sei ed era il
periodo in cui tutti mi chiedevano che
cosa volevo fare da grande e io come
tutti i bambini normali rispondevo il
presidente della Repubblica italiana e
ci sono due storie tra questo ricordo la
prima è di una racconto con mio papà che
mi chiese Per quale motivo dovresti
questa risposta visto che la maestra si
era anche un po' preoccupata no E visto
che ieri non ha nulla a che fare con il
mondo istituzionale e io gli dissi Papi
non mi veniva nient'altro in mente e
così mio padre inizia a capire come
funzionava la mia mente e poi invece la
seconda è il motivo per cui poi decisi
di voler fare il Presidente della
Repubblica Italiana
in realtà è perché credevo facesse le
mansioni abbastanza mainstream tipo la
pace nel mondo dare da mangiare ai cani
randagi portare le coperte alla piccola
fiammiferaia così che avrebbe fatto un
finale diverso e non avrei tanto per
vent'anni della mia vita Scusate lo
spoiler Comunque in pratica io pensavo
che il Presidente della Repubblica fosse
un incrocio tra Madre Teresa di Calcutta
e Iron Man non so se vendo l'idea poi
però arrivò il mio primo mangiatore di
sogni e quando alle medie mi dissero Ma
tu lo sai che fino a 50 anni non puoi
fare il Presidente della Repubblica e
così cercare di capire cosa cosa
potresti fare nel mentre giustamente mia
mamma mi disse Guarda fai l'isola
linguistico poi fai relazioni
internazionali vedrai tu no la strada è
quella e così feci Però nel frattempo
continuavo a colorarli le lettere come
mi avevano sempre abituato a fare forse
anche viste le mie aspirazioni perché
mia mamma mi diceva sempre se vuoi
comandare Devi saper fare e così mi
inizia a fare qualsiasi cosa tutti gli
sport che vengono in mente il violino
l'orchestra e il canto rinnova pallavolo
alla danza poi continuai da sola
rappresentante di classe poi d'istituto
il giornalino il volontariato il teatro
in francese il Teatro Italiano qualsiasi
cosa viene venga in mente Io
probabilmente l'ho fatto perché volevo
riempire il tempo e così Un giorno la
mia professoressa di inglese mi disse
Angelica Ma vuoi andare a fare un
aquaton io non potevo perderlo occasione
di riempire il tempo ed essi di sì e non
sapevo che cosa avrei fatto Non sapevo
però che quella Katana mi avrebbe
cambiato la vita questo perché il suo
compleanno probabilmente non lo sapete
ma è abbastanza normale la catena è una
maratona progettuale 72 ore hai un
problema una metodologia per risolvere
questo problema abbastanza facile il mio
problema era la sicurezza nelle scuole
sensibilizzare gli studenti alla
situazione delle scuole e ci chiede di
fare una campagna pubblicitaria e io
lavorai con un'agenzia creativa per tre
giorni fu abbastanza incredibile uno
perché capii che l'avrei voluto fare per
tutta la vita e in quel momento delusi
le aspettative di mia madre che già mi
vedeva ambasciatrice alle Nazioni Unite
io volevo fare la creativa ma non la
creativa artista voglio fare la creativa
problem Solver quella che risolve i
problemi in maniera un po' particolare e
perché non partire dal più grande
problema dell'umanità la comunicazione e
così mi scrissi da voler fare presentare
Repubblica mi scrissi a scienze delle
merendine e ne vado abbastanza fiera lo
rifarei altrettante volte e così
un'altra cosa che successe dopo aver
scelto l'università è che io quella che
non lo Vinzi e andai due settimane in
Silicon Valley dalle più grandi aziende
al mondo No per vedere come
l'innovazione Stava nascendo sotto i
nostri occhi e non vi parlo dei robot vi
parlo delle idee e la prima volta che
vedevo Qualcosa che veramente va un
impatto e che credevo finalmente a 17
anni che si poteva fare qualcosa potevo
pensare qualcosa potevo anche farlo ecco
quando siamo tornati in Italia insieme
ragazzi con cui eravamo lì Noi avevamo
un obiettivo cambiare la vita dei nostri
coetanei come le avevano cambiata noi E
perché non portare gli acaton nelle
stanze di tutti i nostri coetanei la
nostra generazione
che è la prima volta che noi non
c'eravamo sentiti un numero un voto a
scuola è la prima volta che ci eravamo
conosciuti davvero che avevamo avuto la
possibilità di vedere quali erano le
nostre capacità le nostre conoscenze Al
di là degli schemi normali della scuola
e così nell'agosto del 2019 nasce il
contatto la prima piattaforma Però
facendo online in Italia dedicata agli
studenti alle scuole superiori noi
avevamo Zero competenze tanto tempo e
colorammo le lettere
abbiamo messo insieme tutte le nostre
Insomma potenzialità abbiamo creato un
progetto che valeva perché abbiamo poi
cercato di cambiare la vita tanti
ragazzi come noi e poi nello stesso
periodo venne selezionata per far parte
di weight una community di studenti che
organizzava eventi appunto di formazione
insieme al Ministero dell'Istruzione in
tutta Italia e così la mia vita era
veramente colorata facevo il quinto
liceo facevo io a casa online in
presenza al teatro italiano in francese
andava a scuola i miei amici una figata
pazzesca compie 18 anni e io credo di
avere il mondo in mano pazzesco no e con
i miei 18 anni arriva il covid e quindi
insomma potevo andare sicuramente meglio
arriva il covid Ma alla fine continuavo
a fare gli acathon in presenza a
distanza e poi a un certo punto Arriva
un bando il bando per fare da peer
Mentor quello che stavo facendo in
generale no con gli altri attività
all'expo di Dubai il mondo Cioè nel
mondo intero no con il mondo intero e
dissi che sarei potuta essere lì così ho
fatto application nel frattempo mi sono
diplomata contatto ha cambiato volto ha
iniziato a diventare un progetto per
spingere i ragazzi verso l'imprenditoria
giovanile e voglio Tu continua andare
avanti poi vado all'università Continua
a lavorare con un po' di startup per
capire se la comunicazione
effettivamente il mio mondo è per
fortuna ho Risposte positive e poi esce
l'elenco delle 12 persone che sarebbero
andate a Dubai e tra quelle sei nel
secondo periodo c'è anche il mio nome e
così a 19 anni Faccio i bagagli e parto
per quella che è l'esperienza più
incredibile della mia vita fino ad ora
vado a conoscere il mondo degli adulti
dall'altra parte del mondo lontana da
casa con un sacco di culture che neanche
pensavo esistessero ed è incredibile ma
piena di stimoli e a un certo punto
smetto di sognare
smetto di sognare perché
Perché quando sei abituato a soddisfare
le aspettative degli altri che pensano
che tu fai sempre grandi cose a un certo
punto non sai dove andare perché ti
senti bloccato non ti senti arrivato da
qualche parte e questo succede perché
conosciamo i tanti titoli che raccontano
solo di quelle storie dei ragazzi che
performano in maniera incredibile no E
noi ci sentiamo un po' delle nullità ci
sentiamo piccoli indifesi a casa nostra
a guardarli da casa senza veramente con
toccare con mano quella che può essere
la nostra differenza e quello che ho
capito Io alla fine è che è giusto
trovare dei modelli costruttivi da
seguire però è anche giusto capire che
c'è un po' la dualità dietro le passioni
No non è sempre tutto bello e L'erba del
vicino non è sicuramente Sempre più
verde ci sembra perché non la vediamo
tutti i giorni e non siamo noi a
prendercene cura la verità è che dietro
la mia storia che si è raccontata bene
sembra una storia incredibile molto
colorata e molto divertente In realtà si
nasconde molto altro si nasconde la
perdita due persone fondamentali nella
mia vita che sono stati i miei nonni le
mie figure di riferimento si nasconde la
paura di non essere abbastanza l'ansia
la cosa che ormai noi conosciamo tanto
bene gli attacchi di panico quelli che
non ti fanno respirare quelli che se
alla fermata giusta Devi scendere dalla
metro lo sai ma non ce la fai e quindi
proseguire quella dopo quello dopo
ancora quella che quando ti chiamano i
tuoi amici di stai Usciamo facciamo un
sacco di cose oggi dice no scusa ho da
fare ho tanta roba da finire È vero hai
una marea di roba da fare non la fai
piangi nel tuo letto ti senti una grande
nullità
e va bene così va bene così perché gli
standard che qui siamo sottoposti oggi
la nostra società sono questi sono
questi sono essere perfetti
esteticamente no i social ci raccontano
una bellezza che è unica a quanto pare
perché deve avere le forme al punto
giusto il naso gli occhi la bocca in un
modo preciso devi andare bene a scuola
devi essere il primo della classe il
primo all'università deve avere una
carriera favolosa di avere una vita
perfetta devi andare a ballare con i
tuoi amici devi poter andare a cena
fuori ogni sera di poterlo raccontare
noi continuiamo a raccontarci e
continuiamo ad ascoltare chi ci dice
cosa dobbiamo fare anche in maniera
forse non volontaria ecco quando noi
ascoltiamo sempre le cose degli altri
diventiamo Schiavi dei nostri pensieri
perché non sono più nostri diventiamo
schiavi delle nostre passioni perché
forse non sono più le nostre non sono
più i nostri standard quando noi
dovremmo semplicemente esserne i padroni
e questa è una cosa che succede spesso a
me è successa mi succede tuttora Fino
all'altro giorno stavo piangendo per
l'esame di economia politica cosa
qualche giorno che forse non passerà o
forse Speriamo vada bene in ogni caso
quando sono tornata in Italia dopo aver
smesso di sognare che forse ha 19 anni
un po' Presto no di te come fai Ecco
quando ho smesso di sognare ho cercato
di partire dalle piccole cose dagli
esami dell'università che poi piccoli
non sono e poi ho cercato di capire che
cosa avrei voluto fare Avrei voluto
imparare ancora di più e così ho mandato
un po' di curriculum e alla fine oggi
sto facendo un interchip in
comunicazione marketing in un'azienda è
una multinazionale americana e fa ridere
perché io non posso guardare Grey's
Anatomy senza un cuscino di fianco
perché a ogni scena tipo sangue cose
svengo cioè proprio in maniera
abbastanza eclatante però ecco sono
finita lì un po' un po' per caso un po'
per voglia in realtà perché oltre a
conoscere quell'azienda mi ricorda ogni
giorno che il mio piccolo si è pure io
faccia comunicazione
quello che faccio nel grande aiuta un
medico a salvare una vita e forse è
quello che volevo da piccola no avere un
impatto fare qualcosa che abbia un senso
che abbia un valore Ecco quindi quello
che che vi vorrei dire che è normale
perdersi è normale perdersi è giusto
farlo ed è forse anche la cosa più
importante perché solo quando ti perdi
capisci dove veramente hai bisogno di
andare e quindi quando succede Quando
persi dalle nostre passioni dobbiamo
cercare un posto Io vi auguro di trovare
il vostro campo base in cui far
confluire tutte le vostre insicurezze le
vostre ansie paure e da cui far planare
i vostri sogni perché alla fine tutti
dobbiamo ricominciare a sognare e quando
si parla del tempo delle aspettative Io
sono forse la persona più sbagliata per
dirvelo perché non sono credibile io
continuo a fare un sacco di cose
Continua a cercare nuovi stimoli e
continuo a credere nelle mie passioni
Ecco forse a volte bisogna anche
fermarsi e bisogna capire che va anche
bene e non dover colorare tutte le
lettere perché qualcuno che forse
capisce le cose un pochino più di me e
che abbia qualcos'altro da dire ci ha
raccontato una volta nella lettera a suo
figlio sto parlando di Rudyard Kipling
che se saprei riempire il tempo ogni
inesorabile minuto dando valore a ogni
singolo secondo allora tua sarà la terra
Ecco forse dovremmo semplicemente
imparare ad essere gentili pittori del
nostro tempo perché stiamo tutti
dipingendo delle tele in maniera Insomma
consapevole e con la soddisfazione In
realtà ti sta creando delle opere d'arte
perché proprio come l'arte ogni percorso
se non hai visto con gli occhi Giusti
Non può essere apprezzato Ecco Alla fine
quello che vi posso dire che in questo
caos in questo caso le istruzioni non
servono a niente grazie
[Applauso]